quarante ans de ma vie à traquer les
criminels tout le cocu rien évidemment
pour jouer un flic à la retraite il ya
trois acteurs aux quatre acteurs en
france qui sont mon câble et qui peuvent
le faire et gérard depardieu et le
premier chez qui on a été
c'est vrai que c'est un personnage et
qu'une file sans qu'elle y avait un vrai
ressenti pour jouer de rôle
après deux réunions avec joey starr on a
décidé de dial est quelque part j'étais
je savais que la relation entre ces deux
acteurs et puis du coup ces deux
personnages allaient être intéressante
mais soit ça allait être très difficile
où ça soit ça laisse pas cette façon
fluide
l'idée de travailler avec gérard et
didier quelque chose qui lui faisait la
foutait la trouille mais aussi pour être
honnête le jeu en valait la chandelle
quoique en partie des premiers rôles
qu'on propose c'est encore un personnage
un peu écorché donc forcément je dit
romo cause puisqu'ils me porte moi sic
en cause de quelqu'un quand voit enfin
c'est bon là aussi c'était un truc tout
de suite sur le beau jour le premier
beau jour on va faire ça ensemble
l'installeur tout de suite ou dans ce
cloître partenaires face tu n'as pas ta
pas le cursus il m'a avec points
je pense qu on a eu raison de mettre
notre énergie et la détermination sur
sur ce tandem mais je pense que de voir
ces deux personnages
1 quelle affiche c'est intéressant ces
deux acteurs on est dans un niveau de
gabin belmondo